[Music]
you've seen it in the movies
contact with aliens often ends badly for
humans so why do we keep trying to get
in touch with them we don't even know if
aliens really exist but if aliens do
exist and if they're advanced enough to
detect our existence chances are they're
doing one of two things either they're
avoiding us or they're on their way but
the most important question is will they
come in peace this is what if and here's
what would happen if we broadcast our
existence into outer space whether you
like it or not the search for alien life
began a long time ago in 1960 astronomer
Frank Drake used interstellar radio
waves to scan distant planetary systems
for signs of life the scans came back
empty in 1977 we launched probes that
contained audio recordings of earth and
diagrams of the human body and the
location of our solar system
the probes reached interstellar space in
2012 but we still haven't heard from any
aliens yet and then betting on the fact
that they're closer than we think
Doritos made history in 2008 by
broadcasting the first ever video
advertisement intended for potential
extraterrestrial life as usual radio
silence from the other end our aims just
not interested in us or are they coming
for our snacks are we going to regret
broadcasting our existence into space
it's estimated that the Milky Way galaxy
has as many as 400 billion stars and
more than 100 billion planets to
calculate how many alien civilizations
might exist in our galaxy astronomers
often use the Drake Equation not that
drink
the Drake Equation basically takes every
known star and planet in our galaxy and
filters them through a list of criteria
it determines whether or not they could
host and sustain a functioning
civilization of course there's too much
uncertainty to come up with an accurate
figure another problem is that our
galaxy has a diameter of about 150,000
to 200,000 light-years communicating
within a galaxy of this size becomes a
challenge when you realize any message
we send might be ages old by the time
it's received if we sent a message to a
star system that was 100 light years
away a whole century would pass on earth
by the time our alien neighbors got the
message so whatever we decided to
broadcast we'd have to make sure it
represented the unified intentions of
the world and that it could stand the
test of time but now we have to consider
the possible responses it's a trap and
first of all for any alien species to be
able to receive and respond to our
messages they'd have to be at least as
smart as we are they would also have to
be technologically capable of receiving
a radio or laser transmission but what
if aliens received our messages and
simply chose not to answer some
civilizations may protect themselves by
living in secrecy to avoid being
detected and potentially destroyed by
rival civilizations this is known as the
dark forest theory in which any contact
with outsiders is considered dangerous
it's also possible that aliens have
received our messages and are simply
watching and waiting for humans to
self-destruct
before they come and colonize earth
in the absolute worst case scenario
aliens have received our messages and
they're on their way to earth now forget
what you saw in the movie Independence
Day mankind that word should have new
meaning for all of us today we can't be
consumed by a petty differences anymore
an alien invasion would not be a good
opportunity for humanity to unite
against a common enemy there wouldn't be
enough time if an alien species is
advanced enough to reach Earth from
their home planet they're far more
advanced than we are we don't have the
technology or the infrastructure to
defend against such an invasion and we
probably won't for some time so if we
were to get attacked by aliens humanity
would be easily wiped out before we
could form a globally united front
against our invaders but why do we
always assume that aliens are going to
be wired for all we know intelligent
alien life might receive our messages
and want to work with us of course we
could come up with a whole new number of
possibilities of how making contact with
aliens might play out but keep in mind
that we've been broadcasting signals
into outer space since the 60s and we've
yet to receive a reply for now we just
have to wait and see are we alone in the
universe should we be expecting visitors
anytime soon and just so you know aliens
aren't the scariest thing in the
infinite void of space do you know what
would happen if a magnetar entered our
solar system well that's a story for
another what-if
you
[Music]